how you doing people welcome to the Ruby
report I'm still Dave Rubin I've got
Aaron Foley in my eyes Jobrani wit me
Hannah let's get right to it
have you heard about the camel people
are freaking out about the camel
in Pakistan I let's take a look at the
camel
and then we'll talk about the camel this
is a
that not a real camel don't worry about
that atoms or Star Wars camel
this is a sculpture a camel that
is gonna cost the US State Department
thousand dollars to put it are American
Embassy
being built in Islamabad Pakistan and it
is causing
and uproar the so let's
well let's first go to the State
Department official document explaining
why
this camel is worth $400 out about this
artist product is uniquely qualified
public art which will be presented in
the new embassy should reflect the
values a predominantly
Islamic country according to state
department okay that sounds fine to me
and just as little sino also in the
Bible and in the koran
they both use the metaphor of a camel
passing through the eye
a video for their some religious the
background there they're not just
randomly picking something
a but you know what the 400,000 seems
like a lot apparently we have some
economic problems here
and represented chasing che: pit he's
not happy about this
the american people have a right to know
that their tax dollars are being spent
responsibly especially for
art that the vast majority of US
citizens will never have the opportunity
to view and basically there's been a
whole big Twitter firestorm either is
about everything
four hundred thousand dollars for a
camel a
mas your Persian for you know be about I
but yeah area of
world so take it away well first of all
it's kinda racist I think this
you have a camel art piece in Pakistan
that side of the like but you know what
he gonna go to Africa and put a
watermelon hey what do you know what are
we doing here people state Department
that number one
and secondly I yes a lot of money I
shouldn't
I should have gotten into art yeah does
a cam on what your internet went yes
you know i i host a lot of art events
and on a few guys is comics got you know
what holiday beverage and artisan in the
money that they spend on so many things
and I'm just in there now BC because you
said the new york I could have done that
there yet is it just paint on a canvas
yeah I but somehow this person became
hot and that's how much is worse at work
and I'm sure
we do what we do stand up a lot of times
ago I can do that but
paper this you're a lucky and he of
course is to
cut your ear off and then your art value
yeah goes way up there and I know you're
a
you don't like to spend the money am i
right you like your strict
conservative when it comes to american
Honda money guy was like we were
I could be added that up what do you
think forty thousand dollars is too much
for this type of thing
well you know it's a camel I I just
thought like ghetto americans we pride
ourselves on knock-off
like I feel I can you give me like 10
grand I cambodia Campbell
here particulars 400,000 out link
if you take the whole meal at a bit it's
just like it stupid ceramic km all
it's for its return it was a real camera
me yeah
that's what we should be okay with a
real camera he was gonna predicted just
have a few camels when you arrive at the
embassy in pakistan and that's when you
really will go on in Pakistan
yellows yeah yep isn't part
morning I wrote a catalytic role hidden
cam all are we gonna hide like
CI CIA by in high became a bit late at
night we're gonna solve through and be
like we're gonna
a bad guys power i think thats what it
is that maybe that's why they're
carrying the MoneyGram there'll be a
good anywhere hey mister general
Musharraf yeah Pakistan feedback what is
what I that were here he's on trial
for the a pay general saucer hey what do
you think this camera hope for a week
it is o.o what I would do it go through
it
I ever get a secret that's what it is
yeah I might be a Trojan can I do
anything I could think about was four
hundred thousand dollars and then my
purse right second thought was I
I'm the me to we have to be a sculptor
they are mourning yet clear
yeah I I knew we could bring it to the
NSA somehow
I is this what do you think the where
the government is only spending a shit
load of money on everything every
embassy
everywhere so I don't even think that
has anything to do with Pakistan in the
camel
like they're doing this all the time so
should we ever get upset about this or
she is this exactly what we should get
upset about that word is pissing money
away everywhere
as long as we don't have to mention Ben
Ghazi alright then I think we're far
right maybe they're trying to be like
a well who's gonna run how do we get out
at the bank got the let's do for two
thousand dollars and a cam one another
and whatever the reason is that if they
have some sorta budget set aside more
RN I just got a call about yet no tax
yet
yeah but it well and also it said but
the forty thousand dollar price tag
actually very reduced price but its
culture I might affect
area which I really find that hard to
believe anyone give the US government a
reduced price 0 NE had the US government
ever bought anything at a reduced price
you know they do they mean I V up but
this guy is saying is with that whether
that's with that will blow your mind you
like what some
some a hoe paid even more for the cam
albright but they're like yeah we got a
better person
break them up with the whole needle
metaphor obviously you know me like
they're like alright well the camels and
want to stick am above was taken a toll
and then
you know we're bringin from the Bible in
the current like I just can't like
that's culture we do it with great all
day
within your means I have it written
right here so if the if the camel
contemplating needle I which is
it's a camera fiberglass and to play on
the New Testament phrase
about the difficulty that the wealthy
had entering heaven
course the wealthy are the only ones
that can afford to 400,000 a camel
so I can with its laws are needed art it
wasn't thinking about this when you like
busted out a cam all
you know what i mean it's like we then
we're like our look at the nato and make
this work like he was just like I'm
gonna make it came over to play we just
said is is true it's like that it is is
this metaphor
like you know the poor shall inherit the
earth but only the rich can actually
stop by the poor gamble
act like in that interesting yeah better
for you can afford that you get scared
you'll never be able to afford this
cable
how is this a really good argument
though seriously for for lowering taxes
because we
just put and with tax money and
everything and they just piss away
so is this could this be something I can
see the republican first look at it
Pakistan that scares people but then
also been saying
well see where they're pissing your
money away and I think this is the type
thing that people might be like yeah
we shouldn't be doing it but the
question becomes again what is it like
if they've got a real budget set aside
for if they were like a thing where they
get you guys know
like colleges were sometimes a we have
to hire performers because we have
this money set aside and will use it we
lose it
yes so maybe that's it was that
situation with the guys like I have to
spend forty thousand what we find that
got a camel
is a girls get the camel the fair your
care
if this that situation that then then we
we gotta go in Goa why are we putting
such a big budget on
art at the embassy in pakistan other you
do want to make them as you look nice
get the pictures of president since
their but you know I don't know
art we talk a lot about 1 percent on the
show and an interesting study came out
by say top investment
research breaking down some but the
economics what's going on in america
today
so this is from 2012 the average
household income americans
is about thirty thousand dollars the
average household
a be topped one percenters is about 1.2
million
which is 41 times the average family's
income
the average household up the top .1
percent
is about six million which is 200 and
six times the average families income
so i think is interesting about this is
that you know when you think you're the
one percent
I think people think this is these are
the people that have like
you know an armada of planes that houses
everywhere tear tear
now they do have over a million bucks
which i think probably ought we all
aspire to have been this is America
everybody having but should we be
focusing more
on that point one percent than the 1
percent because that point when that fix
me that's or do we getting into the
alter it although he did that is still
leaving out all the
sucker birds and the people that really
have the big power
given me a lot to chew on their well I
don't know where to begin I never think
about the point per cent 1 percent 02 I
mean
like you just did so like after it that
number gets a large is a good actually
meeting with to me it's a gimmick 69er
migrate could be six billion
I a really good so ridiculous my first
thought was like
well you know within like on Obama's
watch I'm like well I guess the only
good information is it that was a
on a republicans what we'll be talking
about the point 001
making 12 million a year something like
that universally
so much you can do but at the end of the
day ever into the sweet notions that
like
all our country was founded on democracy
its capitalism I mean capitalism trumped
democracy and you can't really blame
people
for going in you know into these money
markets into these hedge fund jobs they
wanna make a lotta money that's their
thing and they make a lot of money and
it's like
its it's a really hard point you just
hope that they at the in the hope that
they give back right
that you're making all this money that
maybe you can take it
you know your personal wealth and do
good things with it and if you don't you
just hope you know that they're
miserable
you know that there are horrible
miserable people are they ever miserable
back to quell there never had a ride a
six million dollars
suppers 10 I look E it the
if that is the things that you I'm
everyone warm but that was saying at one
point I think when they pick on was
crashing that
based on the taxes he was paying because
a lot of his income was of investments
his pain like I'm like 15 percent rate
whereas like
that normal people pain like 30-40
percent say he was making a point about
that personal or
about you know nothing of taxing the
rich a little bit more and finding ways
to get money from them in the other
things I just heard yesterday
it was saying some company for you with
the company was why these big companies
caterpillar with caterpillar was a
underpaid like two billion dollars in
taxes or something because they found
ways to do it
they they moved all their profits to to
a Swiss bank account yes unless we go as
we get upset you gonna do it like I
you know and I'm paying every dollar I
may come paying
fifty cents a that to the government and
there's these big companies are finding
loopholes
yeah that's where you go come on man in
dollars less for a little bit I well
I always look at the Warren Buffett
thing was kinda drinkers you know he say
well my
secretaries paying a higher tax then I
am which always many people
why you pain for so little your day like
if you pay her more than she
closer to your tax bracket paizuri doing
a paper with stocks then then she would
pay then then she would not pay that she
pay
less taxes but it's been is income yeah
so that's that's we get screwed yet
so the part that you brought up is what
this article that was analyzing this was
also saying is that this gap between the
altar rich and the poor
has gotten significantly bigger under
Obama and I think we think we all think
somehow that if the republicans that are
really bad about this but
this is one of these things where Obama
has dropped the ball cuz
the back to the back well I don't know
he's dropped the ball I just don't know
how much
he can do you know in a way it's like
you do you talk about wall street
performer Wall Street that money
fuel for lobbyists new fuels congress
like there's only so much
you're gonna do to stop this money you
know what I mean I just feel like
its you know its it's like that thing
when it when they're like Oh praise a
run for president
you know you like the most popular woman
on the planet she's a cool why would I
give up all that power
really mean yeah I don't lie and have
you been blogging blame Obama conflate
I mean on Obama's election night all the
big wig republicans I got Metro Manila
we're gonna do one thing we're gonna
block
everything that he intends to do and may
have
or they've been very successful at that
so I don't know if you can keep going
back to the Obamacare
I don't think they like black people a
but Leicester
know it's this it is naive to think that
one person is going to make
you'll be able to run everything in our
yard is white house of cards he realize
the vice president to be pulling the
strings yet you know and there's a lot
of things that are
been a back-door deals being made in as
this is a systemic
thing unfortunately unlike a lot of
other countries
do tax you pay more taxes but you
you know you don't have homeless people
for example shows the choice that we
have to make that we want to pay less
taxes
and have all most people are more taxes
and not have almost it was that house
occurring reference your way of telling
us that you think Biden is killed
someone
I think that I have to kill someone and
it's a great show
the it is a pretty great show I how
should we generally feel
about the super rich people I'm not even
talking about that one percent and
the six million people you know that the
people are bringing in sick man dies he
i'm talking about.
the the real the billionaire billionaire
people should we be at like
this George Soros this we just met with
all the potential
Republican 26 you guys make it like they
have to go kiss the rain here they have
just done a great job guys
yeah it's pretty it's pretty sick right
well I mean this morning it comes down
to we have now
left you know restrictions on who can
pay hutu
run for election it's just that you have
a great core yes thank you sir princ
whitewater-related Supreme Court
a so now I can give my you know 10 bucks
the democrats ara it
its so you know it is when you really
think about it you feel powerless and
it's really hardly discouraging but then
you're like
others a sale online and that solves a
lot of
my problems when I think about the
super-rich yet how do you feel
it's like this and then if they made the
money they want to do what they want to
do they can do it it's just
I the the one thing you do start
worrying about is if the
the the disparity continues then you
know
if you look at history every revolution
as my religion
is based on a con economics now so
eventually there's going to be a
breaking point
and so I think at some point the the
country does need to step back and go
okay let's
week we can't have that many more people
that are
their poor and this few that are rich
because eventually
something will yet 106 times the amount
of the average income
these people are making seems like a bit
a hand and the loopholes it is it's
infuriating and now you know it's
unfortunate now everyone's arm so
I mean it literally it could happen it
could happen well on that positive note
II happy Wednesday
as Aaron mention the Supreme Court made
a horrific decision this morning which
is even gonna put more money into
the political system we'll talk about
that next week but let's move on
did you know that Darth Vader
you both step toward is running for
president the ukraine
but don't take my word for it we've got
video proof
the
I
here okay
good yeah
I okay well you've got my vote
yeah I'm not alright so the truth
actually only partially a joke
I hadn't to Darth Vader this guide did
run
in 2012 he would not on the ballot but
he got three percent the writings which
is completely insane
they threw that out because they don't
even count the writing but he did get
three percent that's a pretty decent
percentage
perset Lord water summit his political
actions with my dad in 2013
he was carried in a sedan chair by a
group with Imperial Stormtroopers to
Odessa
City Hall declaring himself acting mayor
of the city citing an order by Amber
albertine and I they said he scored a
record three percent vote in 2012
parliamentary election and both were
never registered because they were
write-ins which rendered them Boyd under
Ukrainian law
but he actually this actually is
becoming something he's running
on the Ukrainian internet party
and a ok and your best
so it to run you have to get you to rate
and 36 thousand dollars the party has
already done that for him so yes this is
obviously a joke
and we can be joking about it but he's
actually doing this to
so it just sorta what we needed to like
get a little sense that ukraine thinkers
everybody's talking about here nobody
sure what's going on ken starr worries
give us a little
momentary how yeah this is the greatest
thing that ever happen to politics
I mean I wanna like you know raise some
money and then
you know your big golden girls fam well
you know
the try to run for election as our
favorite golden girl hanging in there so
i made for a very well my god i would
tell a secretarial and a group for all
them a
yeah you know I think it's its a it's
actually it's so absurd
I mean putting is so absurd the whole
situation so absurd so why not have
Darth Vader
if the mythical James Earl Jones
controllers voice like that really
really
I mean the guy's voice message was
pretty good miss Ukraine in a rush in
with that pretty well and I was like
what is it was the Ukrainian
I think it was my own little way off but
no and no do you think putting
actually NB this guy looking prudence
order would like a rule like Darth Vader
wooden important is a badass he just
crush is people
row I think that he probably saw this in
is like you will destroy that the the
record you know I
the eighth even more evil yeah was
actually made me feel like the guy
me like the it will be interesting if
they get like a mark hamill look alike
as it looks scott Walker's right then
there's like the good
hi I could be kinda funny people are
drawn to the dark side
alright if you were gonna vote for one
or the other you'd probably vote dark
side
with the road are the mean the the whole
bush administration access to evoke a I
was always all yours out the Star Wars
II I honestly think that's how did
explain that the george bush that right
i'm saying is I honestly think that they
will let this
Alyssa Thomas is like Darth Vader no
Arun Jaitley its bill
yeah he will hand deliver yet
I well in revenge in the set you know
there was the big line the push that
about you either with us or against us
and revenge the set which came out after
that
they said it I mean attic in sky Walker
says it to obi-wan Kenobi ahead you're
either with me or your
or your enemies balls with you know
you'd like are you the one who their
puppet government RR
to know that things yeah it just know is
Darth Vader is this like a third party
or is it too is the it's the Ukrainian
internet important but I mean they're
actually raising them I do we need a
little is in our power
our political system it's such a mess
here do we need some like
joke like either comedian to run or
something crazy like that have nearly
ended in the
me that I think well we had a what is a
minute without Al Franken a Minnesota
are you pay pass away now Gary Coleman
ranking
for something anyone provide over with
Yahoo not at all quite a bore
if we talk about okay never take care
with
that was this whole playing going to
talk about the point what birth
that do we need like something like that
to shake or system it's so broke in
right
do everything to be because like the
situation in Ukraine is so tenuous and
its
so a it's really like we haven't seen if
typeof like aggression
in into what and a long time you know
within the aggression between like you
know
you know nora is both the North and
South Dakota North
yeah and fed a lot going on there
let another big boat and let their
people leaving yeah
I like it at my eyes when he said i like
yur from North Dakota I miss your
ok but you know you know a country like
taking over just flat out like I'm going
to take this riot in a very careful
we're gonna but you know
our guards on your border and stuff so
its own serious in its so like oh my god
what's going to happen day today that
its a
a little bit surprising to me that there
is a difference better like oh and hey
both and we gotta
you know and we also have Darth Vader it
like it is by Aaron Hill
the big thing I had a great time I think
that rate I think Darth Vader should be
in every election
yet and yeah I really do think that
deputy director should read it
every country here everyone can be
ordered
yeah I'm the amazing you know how many
people honest to god you know how many
Americans
would raise money and would bow they
what
they would only they're so sick to both
parties yeah
their set with if you if you had maybe
like not a Darth Vader but you if you
had like an American folk hero
right like a I don't know like somewhat
like a look at what
has been Darth Vader america prepares
like that it had Nugent
no not aggressive Iran for eighth-grade
representative in junior high school
and I was the only one running there's
no so I had the way I had the way
yeah i win yeah and I got although both
XO one person at a ride and they
road and Donald Duck so I think I've
Donald Duck grant to help that somebody
like that
something I have a feel good I'm telling
you they would raise a lot of money and
they would get really far because people
are so sick
what's happening in like congress that
there so take a bold parties like if
someone
a yeah I don't grant yeah I believe the
final thought on this
we think George Lucas things when he
sees this stuff like he just had this
idea
around 1974 this little space idea and
it became this thing that is
so beyond barker's huge culturally and
politically
you be watching this companies like this
is some crazy shit
upgrade I mean of course k think I mean
they can know if
if you ever have I you know you do TV
show or you do it
stand up thing area on the shore Smith
three runs up to those soun
you know thank you very much either I
mean can you imagine if the level that
this gathers his character's run a run
for the
I mean is crazy :a right created a
character they want to rule the universe
and now the other guy actually running
yeah 100 Superman Superman could run
for president I'd say it's every people
loves government
when I think I I think anyone I mean
that's what if you did it like American
Idol -style
yet you can end up with the wrong people
if they like is that if you get the
right way of getting the wrong people
anyway yeah
many Christina Aguilera could be running
the country because you have to be like
yeah
phone well we need a lady nato
are about her but Christina Aguilera 26
see there you go
good god alright let's talk about
e-cigarettes because you pride in seeing
these commercials pop up all over the
place for e-cigarette as if they're
somehow
a healthy year than regular cigarette
there seems to be some
debate about that but what any
e-cigarette is liquid nicotine
it's the juice that used to refill
e-cigarette and apparently has some
baidoa FactSet ingested or absorbed by
the skin
especially for children let's look at
the liquid look at that so that that
doesn't look like something that you
want to be putting in your body it looks
very chemical Ian
rose and any smoking and they get you
get no smokes oh okay
so according to The New York Times at
the liquid is ingested or absorbed
can lead to seizures and potentially get
that's not good I even a teaspoon of
highly diluted e-liquid can kill
a small child I am got let's look at the
commercial for e6 in case you haven't
seen when I think you're gonna recognize
the lady
with you you know I'm love being single
but here's twenty don't much like if the
taste like an ashtray
map I'm Jenny McCarthy and I finally
found a smarter alternative to
cigarettes
Louis think lewd that if i three I get
to have a blue without the guilt
because only paper not tobacco smoke
that means no ash
no order which often means I don't think
I've mother
offered to make my hair now I'm a
teacher now are you get the idea
that's why I'm in love with blue you
think now than it was two blue I feel
better about myself
and I feel free to have one almost
anywhere I'm driving at home watching TV
ornament clan and no going up by the
rain to freeze my butt off to take apart
begin with but my blue not worry about
carried
passion I'm one-way known them
by Mick Blue I took back my freedom
okay that commercial is just horrible
but
that aside let's just talk about Jenny
McCarthy for just the second before we
get into their
the real me to this thing Jenny McCarthy
every 10 she's a huge
proponent of the anti-vaccine think it
got her a lot of trouble
is it a little odd that someone would
take such a man a strong stance on one
thing that's
medically controversial and then she
would lend her name to this
could be great Jenny McCarthy be selling
out for the EVE cigarette money
mas what do you think arm it is is very
confusing the whole thing
because as well some you get with I
guess is not there isn't a research on
this
in which is kinda go on with it is
overdue in which pretty much means it
going to kill you
yeah so yes if you're coming from that
place is like oh there's because
the vaccine thing is we sir saying it's
good news is bad and so there's a lot
but this has no research
right so yeah well then the little bit
had to throw it not good
yeah it's going to know it yeah it
doesn't want what is she thinking like
really is this just purely what I like
how does she think
you know we'll talk about fell outside
like how she possibly can she take such
a strong stand on one thing
and then this job on this thing I think
you're giving your too much credit like
she's thinking ahead and
making plans I'm I'm
I'm to help you okay the money that I
she gets back
she took back her freedom a that was the
whole
thought I had no idea she is been
personally incarcerated in our own hell
all these years but the e-cigarettes
overall
you know finally a victory for
traditional smokers
a unbelievable that like that's your
thing now it's like oh do the
e-cigarette nearly with you on Monday
dive kantor kills ball trial there so
many so bad
absurd I thought we were in masks are
some country and get away with the stuff
we all just got just do this
and we'll figure it out later yeah I
thought we were a little more advance
but I guess we're not we're just like
the most about and going okay
will we learn as we go what I think
you're this week while right has in the
e cigarette butt out for him for a while
but now it's the marketing cuz now it's
the commercial
yet are popping up so is this really
just because a bar love technology like
they figured out a way that when I got a
secret to tell everybody we got bad PR
can we make that about technology
everybody loves technology and now
it blew it electric were also but I mean
that the way they sold it to you was
although I mean all the supps the lesson
was good oh there's no smell in there
are all these are those that sounds good
to me I'll smoke a great if you wanna do
you think fantastic fantastic and I
thought wanna
when I first saw that there is more like
kinda like a a
a hookah bar where you go and you right
now does whatever so
as they are these people just smoke in a
little bit a whatever I didn't rosalee
yeah liquid when anything that might
give you you're out on a trip over with
your hammered
you trip over near your e-cigarette
break like all these babies around and I
yeah all the way to let you know what
they were on Treasure bath they rely on
his role in the big entourage
baby um do you guys think it's a little
weird that they're allowing commercials
for this case yes the science isn't
totally the settled yet but they're
obviously some bad the corner we don't
allow
commercials for cigarettes we haven't in
a long time but somehow they got around
that because now they're
electric it's a good point is it out
these commercials running a TV ad for
the know they are you out
seen these great at least in this
company owned by cam or one other for
what philip morris's gotta be somebody
cigarette company has got to be involved
with this that is a good question I
don't know the answer all
or action I've got some bad as the upon
Dark Lord got also like it it seems like
it needs like 10 sorry it live spoofs
growth at the end it's like
this the cigarette girls madrugada like
ghetto don't
don't you know open it don't put it near
like you don't mean ardor and water the
word think
yeah I return to many of these warnings
I mean Iran the attempted suicide all
that is that
I what about people that are going to
say have to let
e-cigarettes exist and we have to build
address because a freedom
what about those by the right was the
man there should be some rules are what
you got your test this stuff at least on
my face
and somebody test on something
before you begin to put it out doesn't
have these pills with you
talking mouse that's just weird I was
hated money as okay
like your mouth being there for us but
cigarette she had better than you what
do you find this year in the comedy
comes out with I'd
I find it so annoying when people are
smoking e-cigarette
I literally say to them I go you have
one more power
and that's only got my way it is the
most in for me it's mostly I look out
he reacting a deal with telephones and
people being like I don't like any of
the deal with like absolute chaos
I wonder how stand-up works at all quite
frankly
and then someone smoking a cigarette and
I said ability of like a
alright you know please put that away to
be distracted she does although it's an
e-cigarette I O
I'm I don't care what it is I just
you're gonna need to stop immediately
yeah like it so I know they're absence
ok its
really yeah and e-cigarettes are you
guys are gonna be joining the cigarette
do you think anyone that doesn't smoke
is gonna join if that's what i think is
interesting here like are they only
marketing
to the people that smoke cleared or they
actually trying to hook
a new generation I think the tornado can
you know it you're here Jenny McCarthy
with their boobs hanging out near
face it's been realigned adding that
I mean I people are gonna be like oh
she's a hot blonde I don't smell like
smoke
you know I'm gonna do yeah for sure if
she would say inaccurate look it take
that my face
yeah then IIIi mister
alright from my from cigarette to air
let's talk about the air in China which
you guys probably have seen a lot about
weed out a couple stories on it
residents beijing's yeah now which is
the pollution iraq
capital up China's Hunan Province
well last Saturday they got a treat they
were provided with bright blue
bags up fresh hair yeah this sounds made
up for from a comedy movie
but not the case let's take a look
where they got to go up into a nearby
mountain
where the air originated it's about 120
miles away from the city that they live
in
and that they got to suck down from air
for a while pretty good
and I what you can see on the right
there this is actual
hand air that is a can %uh air
that they're selling they're actually
selling that in China
and what did that remind me out well as
brother
plant baseball I can assure both you and
your viewers
that is absolutely no air shortage what
they were
yet the cause I birthing room right now
there thanks for calling and not reverse
the charges
by should
hadn't traveled yeah
bad Mel Brooks predicting the future in
space but I can't believe you made space
for rent even before
2011 right now with the show but may
remove the problem I'll tell you what
should I think
yeah I'm part dole will do a little joke
either this is actually pretty serious
is this crazy like is actually not that
there are parts of this planet right now
where they are living in so much
smog you know some pictures where it
looks like bob
but it's actually smug it is pure
pollution that they have to go to
mountain
120 miles away to get there
ya but if I want to give you the money
part first know the best when it says
the
the a Chinese a province received it
treat
on for every a a dream world yeah my
up it really is changed my perspective
on treats you know
I always like I love both gonna do to go
to Del Taco it'll be a train they're
like we did get the rare
that you like an electric cigarette butt
yeah I did you know it air
your own frightening yes so frightening
no like a
we've got a special thing for
self-defense airer
air was thinking about like have kids R
kids like you to read it as
people starving in africa is a good bet
a breeder yeah
people would know franchise yeah yeah
its it's frightening I'll remaining but
the can was kinda quit within the
Catholic so pleasant and have a look
like a
like because I can seem like a bad way
to get a rather on Wearside okay you
made by
I think more pollution with alumina I
remember it like an air so OK at this
point where they should do an
e-cigarette air air cigarette
when you get nicotine an air so it's
good and bad wouldn't like that where to
find the Asian Jenny McCarthy yes both
very few know we're talking about right
now we're gonna have to take the story
before this
but cigarette that aired all coming in
one yeah it was a big thing I am
is this but what can we do because you
know obviously this has something to do
with the amount of pollution that's
going up into
that I fire products from China is that
barrier so it should be over
do we owe the iPhones have an iPhone yes
for my ipod
so we all night at 9 a.m. et I
you to die in a box yet even touch like
this you know I like I like I wanna keep
the chinese input
okay but not for but what really what we
do that because they're going through
their industrial revolution now
much like India we've done it already so
do we have any right
to tell them what to do because look at
me now a revenge legally get over here
we know that the water
from Fukushima is coming to our yeah the
West Coast the United States are now
like we're all connected
I'm so what we do stop party no more
party party out part that out there that
are good
yeah %uh part serb at the so they could
tell us that you know they have yeah
part time with her chariot bottled water
I well yeah I'm 23 it's really
disturbing that that
Chinese go to is not to like our with
crack down on the pollution that
was really you know figure out how we're
going to air quality that's rated and
it's like bad ship these people on a bus
to like a higher area
gears a little tree then get back down
there looks like you know what it looks
like it looks like when
the emergency landing system on an
airplane yeah I meet up again with body
image up but they did it again
but with Russian airplane drop in
altitude
yeah that is yeah it does look like that
but it can you imagine I mean
you know it look easy we can joke about
it but I mean these poor people had to
actually leave their homes
and travel 120 miles into a mountain for
hair I mean this is happening on planet
Earth
is this just like proof with every
science fiction movie ever
I mean every week we do a story that I
feel like science fiction is actually
coming true how young like we are
destroying our
yeah and you know we're gonna have to
move to Mars pretty said
yeah I mean I'm NEVER I was never one
for investing in any type of space
travel honestly
I feel like I'm the only when they get
adamantly opposed to it anything method
at except for their dead space 3 well
you know like hey i jus it feel if you
know what I was most common girls are
crazy to me that we spend like
one billion dollars on my part so I'm
old and no one has text books like I
it makes me insane but then you hear the
stories you know I go well we gotta get
outta this night at some point down
yeah do we have in the planet at some
point yes right yes we do
we do we do you get air can air and you
just
it actually go and it just takes a
rather this was really interesting
scientist are using mood drugs to help
dole
learning new skills and improve
cognitive function
let's look at mental a Harvard professor
used on the pencil
drug that's typically used to treat
Alzheimer's to rewire
the brain up a visually impaired woman
after using the drug the woman was able
to process images
the way a newborn wood and eventually
regain normal
site he also uses epilepsy drug called
Val pro a
to teach tone deaf adults how to find
musical note
this is pretty amazing stop and these
are just two examples
up this kind of thing a and there they
actually think that there's all kinds a
pill that they can give you that I'll
legitimately make you smarter we did a
story on rewiring your brain last week
that the Internet is actually rewire
your brain could look at bone so much
I are we could have like Earth
superhumans
on the way we think its robot that are
going to take over but
you know if enough medication is out
there to change the way we think can
the problem is always the side affects
because they always go o'grady and then
let go but
you know it I'm gonna and one walk
everywhere yeah
really really Moonwalker I'd take that
pill it to up to move one the
but no just got a perk really like to
take this pill mill weird sounds take
that like it just
but also there's that whole thing it
says the pill helps adult learners
passes babies do
and like I was like it with talk about
this whole cognitive processing a
babies have a process information and I
was like really I wanted
it just seems like babies like Ireland
turned
like they don't seem extremely
intelligent to me like they really like
but they rightly guided
took you you to walk yeah I michael
myers me to be like Hitler Complaint
Center
I'm yeah well retained for me to like do
the Rubik's Cube yeah I think it's the
rain
that they're learning reentering they
were in just some money right like you
know if you can take a bill to require
brain I would want it quicker than Mike
there are three years
yeah if you could take a pill to be
martyrs what was that movie with the
neuro and yeah
with whatever whatever Bradley Cooper Ed
Bradley out at we day
would you want to take a pill course
what what I read was going to have kids
and it said that you were you says it
like up to six or seven they
really retain a lot and I was like well
I better start getting some classes for
this kid like a big fan of the piano
lessons are some other
you wanted I mean it would be amazing if
I if you could take a Pill
edges retain everything is how many
times have we like for example names
tourney the comedian had only that I
like seeing somebody albita
a weekend at a club yeah and is he
bringing the manager and the waitress in
the air and and just
dunno what their names are on it like
any name tags you know it yet
you know it's it is it just feels like
that really
it's a thing with america you know
What's Wrong take a pill played out
the way remember them to take a pill
haven't you read a book I wouldn't you
know you like it
it always seems to me like super it so
it was the bath got alright yeah
but I mean this study was really
exciting because it it would help people
like traumatic brain injuries so I'll
give you that but like
some fat ass on a couch like raquet
remember anything amidst our pop in
these pills right so I am I will say it
again I am extrapolating a bit yet it is
being used for medical purposes and
we're just taking it to the next step
area necessarily
diet behind all this but would pardon
the problem be the only rich people
would be or at least wealthy people
would be able to afford this stuff
and then you're gonna have not just a
divide by economics
but literally a smart divide yeah
process its I mean hopefully if this
technology ever came
to fruition and everyone could could
partake in it but because that's how
everything works right at something good
happens after I get it we're not but
it's like i mean
the unfortunately you're right it's it's
the spill cultural ago I'll just take a
pill you smarter and the unfortunate
thing is we don't put money towards
education we don't
we don't help the poor you know giving
them opportunity in raising them and and
so you think I'll take a pill you
smarter
we have a capacity for being smarter but
now how are they getting smarter if you
know if you're not teaching them
its it's very complicated the wealthy to
thought you had to take a pill
yeah things will be fine yeah they have
people think that way
yeah alright people here is very
complicated people do you think that way
and I hope you got a little smarter here
without taking a pill but if you were
taking a pillar smoking something
whether it's an electronic cigarette
earth
whatever doubts that by now but still I
want to thank Erin Foley Maz Jobrani
their Twitterers are right down
below and we will do this next week
thanks for watching